[Music]
when the exhausted straw hats are at the
verge of death
cornered at the port of any slobby by
the countless enormous warships of the
arriving boston call
threatening to obliterate the entire
island at the
very last moment they are saved by none
other
than their ship seeing the pirate boat
arrive
is a heartwarming and tear-jerking scene
that brings the adventure of anna's
lobby to a worthy end
it just feels so cathartic that the ship
has come to protect a crew
and sail with them all one last time
but why how is it that we have built a
relationship
with not a character we love but a ship
it's an easy enough question but after
sitting down to make this video
i had to find out the hard way that it
actually has a really difficult answer
and that answer is anthropomorphism
so once you will have watched this video
and figured out how to pronounce this
word
you will not only be able to use this
technique to improve your own stories
but also have learned a great new word
you can annoy all your friends and
family with
so let's explore how the going mary
seamlessly unites a number of
storytelling devices to create the
perfect adventure story to understand
the entirety of how oda turned a mere
boat into an ingenious story element
we have to look at it from two
perspectives
the going mary as a ship and the going
mary as a character
so what makes the going mary so special
and what are these devices and
techniques that you can use
to take an everyday object and enhance
your entire story with
it to get that emotional reaction from
your audience
i think before we look at how to turn an
object into a character
a great place to start is to understand
the true potential objects in themselves
holds
you see no matter what type of story you
write chances are that they will
not only consist of people characters
wear clothes
swing swords drive cars and eat food
so while all of these things can simply
be part of your story for the sake of
illustration and realism
instead of seeing them as necessary
accessories for your writing
why not make use of these items and make
them part of the experience
to illustrate this point let's return to
one piece because the mary as
a ship actually carries a lot of meaning
and symbolism
that functions as a framework for the
pirate story that oda's writing
first of all the going mary is portrayed
not as a mere vessel for transportation
but as a home for the entire straw hat
crew
the ship is drawn comfortable and
inviting and thus creates a certain
atmosphere in which the crew can relax
socialize
and live together it's a space
associated with positive experiences
and bonding moments for the main
characters
secondly the design of the ship gives
additional characterization to the story
despite being a pirate ship the bright
and friendly appearance of the merry
and most of its rooms immediately tells
us what sort of people live here
this is further enhanced by details like
the smiling lamb figurehead
or nami's tangerine trees that have been
planted on deck
even without knowing anything about the
straw hats
simply looking at their ship alone would
already tell us that these
are good and friendly people and of
course having a jolly roger on its sail
we also keep being reminded that this is
a pirate crew
traveling the seas as a result the ship
and the crew are so closely connected
that when you see the merry
you can't help but think about the straw
hats
thirdly the ship determines the space of
our overall story
by carrying luffy and co from adventure
to adventure
and in the end also closer to the
overall goal
spending time on the ship almost always
tells us that we're about to change
location
and start a new plot thread and in a way
it also functions as a sort of
intermezzo between
arcs where the crew but also the
audience can relax and recover from the
climax of the previous arc
and finally the mary as a ship also
carries a lot
of symbolism in the story or maybe i
should say
it's actually filled to the brim with
symbolism for both crew and reader
alike the pirate flag is a symbol
obviously
for the pirate story we're reading the
tangerine trees are a reminder of nami's
past and home
same as the mary itself is a reminder
for usopp just to name a few
on a larger scale however the ship
symbolizes the spirit of freedom and
adventure
that defines one piece as a story and
the increasing amount of damage it takes
serves as a reminder for all the
adventures the crew has been on
and all the places they have traveled to
so as you see
even when looking at it as nothing more
than a ship the merry already adds
quite a lot to the story and you can be
sure that oda has sunken
a lot of time into its design using an
object to create
atmosphere characterization motion and
symbolism
is a very effective way of drawing your
audience deeper into the story
and make them want to see more of it and
this can be applied to any object you
can think of
like a piece of wood or a ring or even a
chair
to create an immense emotional response
in your audience
but there's even more that you can do to
an object
you can actually make it into a
character itself
i'm definitely not the first one that
calls the going mary a part of the straw
hat crew
and i strongly believe that mary as a
crew member does a wonderful job at
enhancing the characters and the plot of
the story
but how exactly can you give
characterization to a ship
or any object at that this is where the
wonderful term from the beginning of
this video comes into play
anthropomorphism so what exactly is that
anthropomorphism is a literary device
that assigns
human characteristics to non-human
entities like
animals or inanimate objects so now you
might think
well that's great and all but why would
you want to do this
because if done right it introduces
something unusual
and thus captures the reader's interest
and empathy
anthropomorphism is actually quite
popular these days
and of course animated manga are no
exception for this
in the case of the going marry i'm of
course talking about the ship's spirit
that takes on human appearance in the
form of the club outdoor man
as frankie explains to us this is a rare
manifestation of a ship's soul
made possible by the love and care given
to a ship by its crew
thus the small figure that usop
witnesses repairing the broken ship on
skypia
is actually mary herself in other words
the mary being alive
is not a metaphor she can actually
communicate with people
and this is also not exclusive to the
straw hats when mary wants to save her
crew from anna's lobby
she asks iceberg to repair her for one
last journey
this i think is important because while
mary gains human-like characteristics
she still shows mostly traits and
interests associated with the ship
and thus focuses on being a great pirate
ship
repairing herself and carrying its crew
through any hardship so
what then is the consequence of this
technique well the first thing that you
will notice
is that when humanizing an object it can
start forming relationships with your
characters
or heck it can even become a main
character itself
the mary undoubtedly has formed a bond
with all of the straw hats
but luffy and usop in particular
actually communicate with her
usopp promising to repair her and luffy
apologizing
for not taking better care of her
secondly
the going marry offers a completely new
direction for the plot line
she is the cause for stopping at water 7
in the first place
to look for shipwright that might be
able to repair her and thus
triggering the entire water 7 in any
slobby saga
which i shamelessly admit is my favorite
in the entire story
but even more creatively oda actually
uses mary to save the crew from anna's
lobby
this i believe is an especially strong
moment because the straw hats
just declared war against the world
government to save robin
and despite being fought over and
ultimately abandoned
mary had such a strong connection to the
crew that she was compelled to ask
iceberg to fix her so she could save her
crew
one last time and against all odds
having that love and loyalty rewarded by
the ship that came alive through these
emotions in the first place
is just a very powerful moment and so
lastly the mary functions as a link
between all of the straw hats
she was the place they all forged their
relationships on and got to travel
together
and thus we really feel it in the end
when mary gets a viking
funeral and has to say goodbye to her
crew
it's not just feeling sad for a ship
it's feeling sad for a real character
and in the end we even get some
catharsis with the spirit of mary being
able to keep
accompanying the crew on the rest of
their journey
so that's it for today guys if you enjoy
one piece and want to learn more about
storytelling
world building or my thoughts on the
latest one piece chapter
make sure to like and subscribe to
become part of the channel
right now i hope to see you around next
time and
until then stay safe and have a
wonderful week
you